[Musica]
l'impronta
che fame
c'è qualcuno
pronto
sì
mi sto aspettando adesso
non mi vorrai mica rubare il pane
[Musica]
internet no
andiamo tornare anita che cosa era lo
store umore che non è sentito il rumore
strano no non c'è niente di strano sto
solo facendo il bagno vedi
tutto che è
sì perché che cosa vi sta lì nascondendo
niente non sono accodato niente hai la
faccia di una che nasconde qualcosa si
sta nascondendo proprio niente perché
pensi che si sta nascondendo qualcosa
non ne sono tanto sicuro poi vuole
tornare a mangiare posso tornare a
mangiare
wow e quando mi ricapita un'occasione
così ciao
per fortuna vitale che è cascato e se ne
ha dato
deve scoprire che è successo di nuovo ha
trasformato di nuovo in una sirena ma
chi è stato questa volta non ho raccolto
nessun ciondolo non ho toccato niente
non ho fatto niente
una cosa è certa è meglio che glielo
tengono a scotto vi ricordate la scorsa
volta le sue soluzioni
è meglio che non lo sappia anche perché
non è colpa mia io stavo solo facendo il
bagno il problema è che le bolle stato
svanendo si stanno scoppiando quando
tutte le donne scoppieranno vitale vedrà
la coda che sto tenendo nascosta co
che cosa faccia fare nasconderla all
idea aggiungerò altro bagnoschiuma e
così forse
aumenteranno le bolle
guarda che ho sentito tutto adesso vi
spiego in quello del successo va bene ma
non ti stanno esplodendo neri ho solo
detto che andavo ad aggiungere un po di
bagnoschiuma per fare un po più di bolle
vedi
ma tu che cosa hai sentito esattamente
ho sentito che mi stava nascondendo
qualcosa e poi sento anche
una puzza di pesce che cos'è puzza di
pesce
forse dalle finestre dal mare
mi sembra che non stai avuto pene sai
senti cose strane se il giocatore tra le
porte bene se vai a mangiare qualcosa di
così o no non ci casco più che ogni
volta mi mandi in cucina a mangiare poi
dopo mila schon di qualcosa adesso mi
racconti che cosa è successo
cos'è quella cosa verde lee kai sulla
gamba e
no niente il mio costume da bagno per
questo pezzo leste da bagno non beh
allora se non mi stai nascondendo niente
vorrà dire che slaughter non la vasca
una volta svuotata tutta l'acqua non ci
sarà più niente da nascondere giusto
nodo anno svuotarlo potrebbero essere
molto pericoloso non ne vuole più
i freni studies portare l'acqua ok notte
invece figlio tempo
bene
come sono adesso
ho detto che non toglierò
centinato subito
dove il tempo non abbiamo più
che cosa è successo qui per fortuna è
rimasta un po di acqua o no una donna
sirena di nuovo
sì lo so per questo che non volevo
dirtelo fuoco dove è stata colpa mia
questa volta però un modo che potrebbere
una soluzione perché altrimenti non
potrà più camminare come pazzo non
possono anche ossia fuori dall'acqua
era meglio se andavo in cucina a
mangiare mi stavo
male si certo certo
questo pensiero certo che ti voglio
aiutare
però un po di aria fresca
alla fine sono utili queste
il sentito cos'era
puoi controllare sì sì sì sì
c'è qualcuno
si
è come dio ho trovato questa tavoletta
qui con un messaggio per te un messaggio
per te per me ma da parte di chi non lo
so
o no se le gambe indietro vorrai tutte
le mie prove superare dovrai se fallirà
e mai più camminare potrai un nuovo
cattivo non so chi sia ma ci aspettano
delle nuove sfide e soprattutto tutte le
sfide faranno con la coda da sirena sarà
molto difficile questa volta non come
quelle del lupo mannaro vi ricordate
questa volta non potrò votare le gambe
la challenge si fanno sempre più
difficili ma come farai a dormire questa
notte non puoi mica uscire dall'acqua no
non posso uscire dall'acqua trofeo
dormire qua non nuovo schema bagno non è
proprio a scomoda però non è neanche
tanto comoda devo dire ma è l'unica
soluzione
voglio il mio letto
7 dubbio quale la volte da bagno
[Musica]
anita
capitale
ciao come stai oggi
devo dire che costava dormito abbastanza
bene strano che devo dormire nella vasca
e non del letto ma è l'unica soluzione
adesso con questa coda
mi sento un po come un pesce fuor
d'acqua
ma prima o poi riuscirò a tornare
normale vero
spero proprio di sì che riusciremo a
risolvere questo
problemino
problemino non posso camminare devo per
forza stare nell'acqua e ti sembra un
problemino è un problema
sentito
sembra che provenisse dall'altra stanza
vuole controllare sbrigative un posto
camminare ok no che vado
questa
è un messaggio forse di chi mi ha
trasformato in sirena che cosa dice ciao
all inter la prova di oggi sarà trovare
tutti i pop hit nel mio elemento nel mio
elemento ci sono anche delle onde ho
capito
credo il mio elemento dovrebbe essere
l'acqua visto che stiamo parlando di
sirene quindi devo trovare i compiti
nell'acqua questo più montare in piscina
e trovarli questa è una delle prove
sembrano abbastanza facile come prova
credo o forse diventeranno sempre più
difficili beh comunque devi portarti in
piscina di riportarmi in braccio per
mino posso camminare in giochi loro
pessina va bene ti prendo io adesso il
braccio e ti porto subito in piscina
così risolviamo subito questa
maledizione
da the dawn in piscina da sirena e si
sono ipocrita nascoste nella piscina
riuscita a vederlo se guardate bene nel
fondo della piscina si riescono a vedere
persino a recuperarli tutti sono
tantissimi
quanti saranno secondo voi provate
indovinare qual è il numero di pop hit
nella piscina e vediamo alla fine del
video che si è avvicinato di più al
numero è giusto ok e iniziano però a
prendere il potere
riuscirò a ruotare da terreno
e bellissimo avere la coda
in effetti sì proprio la bella sirena
beh però stai attento quando vai a
prendere i popoli e va bene proprio
realtà io mi butto ok io ti seguo da qui
come l'acqua e
prova a prendere il primo può qui bari
vediamo che cos'è
devo capire bene come nuotare con questa
cosa non è facile essere sirene sembra
facile ma non lo è ho imparato
tanto dai che ci sono tanti pop hit
league ci aspettano per prenderne uno
[Musica]
il
bambino
durissima
[Musica]
credo che abbiamo recuperato tutti
profit penso
dobbiamo contarli adesso
sto allenando la coda ancora non riesco
a nuotare bene con questa cosa da sirene
hanno trovato tutti i propri team
troviamo vediamo eccole qua
c'è qualcosa corsa al tuo corpo
abbiamo dimenticato quello lo prendo
subito
vai
[Musica]
il o raccontiamo tutti i pochi e quindi
non
aiuta
giunto ora mi devo le imprese dai almeno
qui e meno profondo vi prendo subito by
[Musica]
cioè adatto la piscina dai ce ne sono
ancora un paio di
stancante per una sirena è
brava nei presi due
sirena ma
siete un mi piace per portarmi fortuna
due brani raccolta e ten è rimasto solo
uno da prendere quello lì per due a solo
due
gli ultimi due
siamo fatta eccoli qua gli ultimi tre
papi tra ora non montiamo quanti ne
abbiamo presi vediamo chi ha indovinato
ok vediamo quanti sono 2 3
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 erano 13 pop hit avete
indovinato
devo dire che questa sala è già stata
stancante con questa coda gigante da
essi non deve essere facile notare con
quella coda
lodiamo il mio pop hit preferito fra
questi
il pesce rosa che si erano sotto
il mio rimane sempre il coccodrillo
sempre in ambito acquatico e là sotto
guarda è il vostro preferito qual è ma
ora che abbiamo terminato questa
challenge quali altre challenge ci
aspetteranno lasciate un mi piace per
scoprirlo e ora vi lasciamo con quattro
case linee su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite
ciao
dove siete finiti perché sono stop
[Musica]
cover lizza tormento questo
alla paghetta di ieri
un nuovo messaggio
scampia e pop hit sott'acqua
questa è la challenge di oggi
[Musica]
bellissimo queste gonfiabili comodissimo
beh io dormo fa da sirenetta ciao verri
dover lido interessato a questo
gonfiabile
vorresti mangiarlo vero per la
saluta ciao
a tutti
e così qui aiuto il mento vista
trasporta vita dall'altra parte e
youtube egli è fermarmi vitale
in vetta mi vuole portare via
ti aiuto io ad affondare eccomi tornata
eccomi qua devo tornare all'inter natale
e così dovremmo cambiare i pop eater
volta acquaro vodafone darti aiuto
ok ora siamo pronti per la challenge
scambio copit marche sta facendo vitale
e
buttiamo giù vitale
ho captato il gonfiabile
[Musica]
primo scambio
secondo la fine del bio volete scrivere
secondo voi chi ha fatto gli scambi
migliori ovviamente la7 mi piace entro 5
secondi
[Musica]
è il mio preferito terzo
cambio fallito voglia più bambino e il
polipetto
andato anch'io voglio più parli non è
giusto
[Musica]
farlo e scambiato a
24 ottobre
ora
i picchi
di un momento vincendo non lo so ci sono
tanti pop hit che mi piacciono come
il coccodrillo il gran cetto sott'acqua
il più difficile vedere se tu quasi
intera un 3 2 1
[Musica]
ma tumori
è caduta la camera per terra dove niente
è come scambiare i puffi bendata per me
non si vede niente
dopo vediamo che ha presi cobit più
belli si sa che sto sono più fortunato
io vedremo due dura
[Musica]
marchionne ha accettato il mio
triceratopo
perché la miope rende più bella quindi
mi dispiace per te ma non è certo è che
allora non lo scambio
che cosa è cambiato non ho visto niente
fosse qualcos'altro di più carino e
profit a casa perché non è troppo
divertente
ultimo round 3 2 grazie
migliaia
[Musica]
di forme di vita come ultima prova
proveremo a darci un bacio sott'acqua
però secondo me sarà un disastro
proviamo e
riproviamo
32 euro
[Musica]
riproviamo l'ultima volta
unità
ma ti sei dimenticato che dobbiamo far
vedere hip hop il sì è vero allora io
sono qua nella vasca da bagno perché non
posso stare fuori dall'acqua quindi
questo è il mio nuovo eletto non avete
visto gli episodi persino impiantate poi
a vedermi comunque questa challenge io
ho preso la balena e il corpo invece
rosa che sapete dalla scorsa challenge è
uno dei miei preferiti
questa è quella di cui si voleva
liberarvi da in quale challenge militare
ha vinto per tale da scrivetelo nei
commenti vediamo se avete visto che fino
al trinity poi l'anguria bellissimo
preso il limone e ovviamente la cover ti
ho preso il coccodrillo
pinguino di bitonto ba l'eroe di un
casco di banane questo pezzo di
mettermele così in testa il famoso casco
di banane il grechetto che mi piace un
sacco quello che aveva detto di no allo
scambio all'inizio mi sembra davvero
quelle dovute dai due poli di più ma ero
sott'acqua
poi un arcobaleno e perdonare
quella batteria
cambiare
qualche cosa
che fai color arcobaleno piccolino
il mio preferito potrebbe diventare
questo ma rimane comunque il suo padre
cento
nell'arco balerna sia anche l'arcobaleno
euro tra i miei preferiti e per i miei
preferiti
proviamo a fare canestro
facciamo i tributi allora studenti nati
nella mia veste che anche il mio letto
di miniere
[Musica]
ma mi sa che fare
eppure stato nascosto e quel
tipo di emergenze dove di un verso
anita dai l'ora di mangiare
non mi ricordo mai nascosto quel
cioccolato forse sta dietro
[Musica]
forse non lo sono mangiato
ma primo ti ricordi dove l'ho messo
a vita dai
briga 10 fuori la via normale
ma non capisco non capisco proprio come
abbia fatto a scomparire questo cibo sei
stato tu merlino hai mangiato tu il mio
cibo
uno si nasconde il cibo adesso lo devo
riordinare
pronta l'ha
travolto l'ho portato una tonnellata di
cibo qui
è il martino 6 forme pure tua
ma sei stato talmente tanto tempo in
acqua che sei diventata blu
sì
allora voglio
un chilo di pasta
come
perché è successo lo pone è diventata
russa
si portava in tutto il prima possibile
ci sentiamo dopo ciao
cosa che sta succedendo sai che mi un
dolore
questa trasformazione inserire sta
trasformando anche i capelli ma è tanta
fama che tu vero se diventa
ti capisco ti capisco
e chi sei
chi è no non mi capito
come ho preso tua vita prese mangiata
per chi è stato tu lo sai che è stato
effettivamente le assomiglio un sacco ma
non è che lei mangiata poi lai assorbita
e
se è diventata come lei tipo non capisco
come lei assorbita lei mangiata non
capisco cioè io adesso devo vivere con
te che mangi le sirene in effetti sempre
proprio una murena
ti porteremo fatti
[Risate]
[Musica]
non ci credo che era eliminata ho
mangiata sicuramente l'avrei nascosta da
qualche parte dimmi dove
è troppo tardi verrà eliminato anch'io
berlino viene mangiarti questa murena
vieni berlino aiutami
[Musica]
ho trovato il suo punto debole ha paura
di essere mangiata a berlino
bravo mourinho bravo e adesso dimmi
subito dove anita altrimenti il
guinzaglio berlino addosso
[Applauso]
in piscina come ho fatto a non pensarci
dove poteva essere altro ovviamente era
in piscina non può uscire dall'acqua
vabbè lascerò qui merlino a controllarti
berlino dall'acuto mare
per andar lì non vi riguarda questi si
potrà controllare
berlino non fartela scappare
con bambini ha detto
bravo metri non controlla
tale
6 forse vitale mi ha fatto uno scherzo
mi ha portato fa mentre dormivo ma
perché
che cosa sono quelli non hanno un'aria
amichevole
aiuto
[Musica]
riferita così via sono rifinito c'è un
grosso problema nel piano di sopra c'è
qualcuno che ti somiglia nella vasca da
bagno e una sorta di sirena cattiva la
sirena cattiva
ora capisco qua nella piscina ci sono
delle creature strane ogni tanto
spuntano fuori e mi stavano mordendo la
coda credo che vogliano mangiarmi
dobbiamo sbrigarci devo subito
nasconderti fuori dall'acqua perché sono
sicuro che sta arrivando
non puoi nascondermi fuori dall'acqua io
non posso fabre a vivere fuori dal bar
quanto contenere la coda a bagno come
fai a nascondermi ho un'idea ci porterà
fuori dall'acqua ma ti terrò fuori solo
lo stretto necessario per fare in modo
che la coda non si sia chi troppo e mi
devo occupare velocemente della sirena
cattiva per sistemarla per sempre
hai già un piano per eliminarlo per
spero di sì qualcuno che si avvicina
sbrighiamoci a quarto miglio da qua ok
qui all'ombra non dovrebbe essere male
di sicuro che questo è un buon
nascondiglio non sono molto nascosta
l'importante è che sei all'ombra così
tanti secche rai poi le tenderemo una
trappola
non ti preoccupare vedrai o un piano in
serbo per lei va bene mi fido del tuo
piano ma ricordati di spiegarti perché
non posso stare troppo tempo fuori
dall'acqua anche se sono all'ombra però
nel frattempo dimmi qual è il tuo piano
ok allora innanzitutto di richiamare la
sirena qua
qui pc notte e poi al resto ci penserò
io occupare chiamare da qui ma io non
dovrei nascondermi dovrei chiamarla qui
non ha senso questa volta non ci
preoccupare un piano geniale e va bene
io la chiamo ma tieniti pronto ok
berlino non sta più facendo la guardia
alla sirena cattiva quindi vuol dire che
sta arrivato qui
sirena cattiva
numero
sono qua stai cercando me vero sono qua
vieni pure non ho paura di te
ci mette ad arrivare
eccolo
capitale dice che una mia sosia secondo
me non mi so niente ei murena
murena
che
li alle gambe allora non è una sirena
perché vista le ha detto che una sirena
se alle gambe
iniqua che qualcosa per te
che cosa ha in mente deve stare molto
attento o una conchiglia magica
anch'io
perché
maledetta morena mercati questo
chiedo scusa se ho mai usato spingermi
in acqua
con l'acqua che trasforma del sirena
adesso un piano malefico
questa pura e li murena tanta non puoi
camminare hai la coda
adesso che l'ho trasformata in sirena
buttandole dell'acqua addosso posso
finalmente intrappolarla con il mio dono
gigante
sto arrivando
troppo di una pezza ci credo
bravissimo vitale
guarda
ed è guardabile
piano geniale 6
la coda
l'italia
[Musica]
bravissimo se sì siete eliminarli ma
dove è finita è scomparsa c'è più niente
nella piscina si è volatilizzata ei ma
non si sono neanche gli squaletti piu
castrati moretti meccanici vabbè
l'importante che se volete sconfiggere
la nemica
e ora possiamo andare a mangiare
tranquillamente
ciao
[Musica]